[Musique]
diamant de merde
à un moment ça va ça sent le cannabis
dont l'origine est les gamins comme en
super tout cas les temps je suis
contente que tu sois là tu m'as vraiment
laissé le choix super c'est que c'est
une mauvaise idée là j'aime pas les
gamins arrête ça fait très bien passé
sauver leurs âmes mes élèves c'est juste
une fois pouvoir et tu t'es pas payer
une école de dessin 5 millions euros par
an pour rien
l'école de dessin ah oui l'école de
dessin ouais voilà tous leurs montres
tes trucs deux seins c'est simple par
contre si jamais il peut demander de
faire des bonhommes tu dis non pas que
bonhomme trop simple dalle temps je
t'aime
[Musique]
salut je suis remplaçant madame brodier
que les malades
elle a alors viendra quand elle va
revenir la prochaine fois ce mois je
veux pas rester au nez des cours à des
mots 20 à 10 ans non non c'est quoi
montrer moi vos dessins on va perdre du
temps comme ça c'est très bien
ouais super moche d'accord nul au bourg
pour ios se dégage ouah ça fait ça tout
seul sans rire c'est nul tu as quel âge
de 10 ans oui il vous plaît déjà à oui
c'est super non mais c'est pas tout à
fait ça c'était parents troisième sissy
c'est moi et vous montrez vous dis ça
alors mais moi j'ai moi j'ai pas mes
dessins avec moi mais c'est insensé
comme c'est comme ça là mais en mieux
dre les proportions assure un peu claqué
alors on va commencer le court
on peut discuter des bonhommes non
aujourd'hui on va fin ouais voilà donc
le cours d'aujourd'hui ça va sur la
perspective
mais si on l'a déjà fait ouais bah on va
faire le fusain ça aussi les couleurs
primaires la vesa de semaine dernière
alors à faire des bonhommes des think
you're gonna je sais pas moi qui décide
un bonhomme du fer
[Musique]
vous inquiétez pas les enfants aucun
problème
oh
il est vieux qu'on dit si je joue serait
non je sais pas ok les enfants on va
dessiner le bonhomme devant nous
requérons immense que tu connaisses à
l'émission c'est vous qui dessinaient
mieux je bavais les bateaux participant
prend une fois y inclure disney
il
âgé plus d'encre dans mon feu de bois
joli kg au prix d'un titre
comment bien plus de feutre il ya plus
de temps donc je me suis impatiente
montrent comment vos dessins notre
morale et de sara lee ouais c'est nul
c'est nul ça n'a pas évolué c'est
dégueulasse et des culasses est donc
totale même pas compris ce qu'il fallait
faire on va creuser ça allait super
voyez ya des écouteurs avant mais c'est
super peut-être va-t-il rester non je
donne moi peut pas laisser moi non non
excusez moi mais c'est le mauvais sens
et m'accueille dame
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette nuit on descend monsieur mais j'ai
pas de faute
[Musique]
tournez vous déconcentrer là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en fin de match super vote des sens il
était bien qui est super j'espère que
vous reviendrai bientôt
yes c'est loin expliqué bon alors
comment cela s'est passé s'est bien
passé je crois qu'ils m'aiment bien moi
c'était pas la mort je m'aime bien m'a
tout l'air n'en parle pas elle est douée
mais alors quel poste et collant des
questions à madame je frenche poireau
donner des cours faut que je vois faut
que je demande à l'église
maman tu penses internet en carène de
fumée les nappes et les sexes
merci d'avoir regardé mon court métrage
n'hésitez pas à cliquer juste en dessous
là pour découvrir le making-of on voit
comment on a fait les effets spéciaux
comme on a fait la lienne comment s'est
passé le tournage et n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner à 12 millions ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir très un jour je ne
sais pas à bientôt
laquait